hey what's up guys my name is a China
welcome to episode 4 of network chat
programming first of all if you haven't
watched the github tutorials there is a
link in the description to a playlist
which contains three tutorials you might
not have through yet because I only made
two so far but it will have three in the
future might have three already I'm not
sure it depends when I upload this video
but check that out because that'll teach
you how to use github and how to you
know leave comments and all that good
stuff that you should I reckon I'll
recommend you check them out um but
anyway today we're going to actually
talk about making these fields do
something so if we check out our design
here or if or if we even open the actual
application which I'll do in a minute
once this loads come on pass it already
brah ok that's what the application
looks like if we hit the debug button
we'll see it to provide over here which
is awesome um and you know we can do our
name blah blah and the point is when we
hit login
the idea is to login so we're going to
talk about how to actually extract data
out of these text fields and how to well
how to login essentially we're not going
to actually cover that yet because that
will take a while but we will talk about
how to extract data from these fields
how to convert them into variables ah
when we hit the login button okay so the
first thing we should do is probably
talk about lessness what is an action
listener now I think we talked about
this before in fact yeah we would have
because in 3d game programming we
actually did we actually did make a form
for the configuration and we yeah we did
make a form for the UM configure for the
options so you could like set your
resolution and whatever so we're gonna
do a similar thing and obviously if you
haven't seen that well not everyone has
seen that so yeah but we'll talk about
that right now so what is listener an
action listener is essentially just a
way to listen for if an action is
performed on a particular component in
our window and if it is we can handle
that
so um and exactly the best example is
probably when we click a button right an
action has occurred towards that button
that buttons action performed is when we
click on it right for text fields for
example there's a there's a vast array
of things you can handle for example if
we type a letter if we remove a
if you actually right click on any
component here and add an add an event
handler you can see all the different
there are actions or events you can
handle such as you know the carrot
updates the carrot is obviously the
blinky thing when you type so that you
know where you're typing you know focus
when against focus or loses focus a
input method kappa position whatever
there's so many things key when we when
we press a key when we release a key
when we type a key but when the mouse
will use what basically the deal is we
can handle any of these things so we can
run our code if one of these things if
one of these events were to occur so the
idea is when the user hits the login
button we want to handle that action by
logging in okay so let's right-click on
that this is the cool thing that window
builder result we don't have to tap out
the code ourselves if we right click on
the login button go to add event handler
and then action and then action
performed ah let's just click on that
and what you'll see in the code here is
this little thing just appeared all
right this right here and basically what
that does is just grabbing some water um
what what that does is you can see if
there's an action performed it's in and
it's an anonymous sub method here or sub
um was actually called I don't know
basically it's an anonymous constructor
and Method what we can do here is let's
just I like to change that to a just for
no reason at all just cuz I don't like
r0 but basically it is a and I think
actionless needs an interface yep it's
an interface this interface obviously
has to implement a particular method
which the action performed them all
we've done is instead of actually going
here because we could have done this
right we could have made a custom class
called sorry I costume fast just
whatever I actually let me just explain
this because I don't think I have before
and a lot of people understand that
let's just create a class called a login
button okay and this is honestly a bit
of a waste of card cuz you don't have
because for this for this example it's
useless but what we can do here is a
with login button we can implement
implements actionlistener right and
obviously once we do that we'll have to
add the unimplemented methods which as
you can see is action performed the
method that appeared there right and
once we've done that what we can
actually do is hit up less you say how
it is so private
for example private login button our
handle just called handle equals new
login button all right and then instead
of having this all right I'm going to
cut that you can just put that in here
that's called handle all right
and as you can see that doesn't give us
an error or anything because the thing
is this parameter has to accept an
action listener right that's a class
that is of type action listener which it
is since we've implemented it and then
over here we could put our system dot
out dot print line button pressed yeah
and then if we run that code really
quickly and hit the login button you can
see that over here in the console every
time I press the button button Proust
appears because that's what we typed
here so that's basically what we're
doing except instead of us going ahead
and saying let's write an entire class
we don't have to do that okay what we
can do is instead just simply hit up a
new action listener then as you can see
it automatically appears here as an
anonymous ah
god I keep forgetting was called um
let's just quickly check it out
anonymous inner type there it is so it's
an anonymous inner type which basically
means that we're declaring the class as
an anonymous class because we're not
giving it any value we're just simply
declaring it for a single use which is
what we've done here okay and then that
saves us having an extra class here
which is probably a good idea because
it's unnecessary suppose delete that and
let's delete this as well okay so that
hopefully that helped you guys actually
realize what's going on here because it
can be a bit confusing but yeah and then
obviously over here we can simply type
our hello
or whatever we want here and if we run
that whenever place log in but you can
see hello appears here okay so that's
how that works brilliant um let's see
we're seven minutes in okay that's a lot
um okay so let's actually cover a simple
login command here
so since we know that whatever one's
here
whatever happens sorry when we hit the
button whatever is in between these
curly brackets is actually executed
let's run a method called login okay and
login will actually just log us in look
create the method login created as a
private method it's actually created
here but we don't want it here what's
created over here you know in the actual
class not inside the instance of
actionlistener
and over here this is basically what's
gonna happen when we login so in fact I
could just add quick javadoc comment
being like ah login stuff here or
whatever okay so that when we mouse over
here it always happened it'll disappear
yes just so you guys can see if haven't
proven up I do that as users but I don't
really don't like adding comments unless
I'm making some kind of a bi that's just
how I roll unless it's just comments
like a to do comment or whatever anyway
um so what should happen right once we
hit the login button what we basically
want to do is extract data from fields
and open a new window which logs us like
logs I'll see and hopefully you know if
it works
so that being said the fields that we
want to extract right right now I just
basically text fields so we have the
text name address and port that's
actually perfect that's all we want
right so let's make the best way to
probably do this is to actually have the
login take three parameters so the
string name string address and int port
okay and then over here we'll put our
fields here because we want to actually
open a new window here very soon which
will actually pass these commands in
these variables okay
so let's talk about how we can actually
extract these right so
make a quick string here called name and
that's going to actually take our and
our name from the text field directly so
well what we call it called it text name
so over heals put text name which is the
our text field dot get text right and
that will just return the text of the
string very simple so that's name we can
do we do two more times for the address
so text I think it's address right get
text and finally since we want a
viewport to be an integer we actually
have to pass that so text port dot get
text but we need to help integer dot
pass and to convert it into an integer
because it's a string originally and
then we can just hit up name address and
port okay and that will basically pass
them into this method here okay so
that's pretty simple
you should probably handle this and say
for example if tech support is on number
of or vehicle something you know let's
handle that and we can do that later we
probably will do that later but for now
it's gonna keep it really simple
okay so now that we pass into here let's
do a few things first all we want to
open a new window and we'll talk about
that next time but we do want to open a
new window and we also want to close
this window or I want to dispose of it
so you can simply type dispose right and
that will just basically get rid of
window it won't close your application
obviously it'll just get rid of that
particular window and let's also just
print over here just for fun our name
and our address and our port okay just
so we can see them here so let's just
open it let's type the name to be the
churner address to be legislator ocol
host and the port to be a one-line to
incise our example let's hit login our
window disappears and as you can see our
strings appear
here and our program actually terminates
because there's nothing left for it to
run since we've disposed of this window
but yeah the Turner local host add 1 9 2
okay so you can see all of our data here
and that's what we're going to use to
actually log in in real in real life I
guess but yeah anyway that's um episode
4 hope you guys enjoyed it if you did
please hit that like button and I'll see
you guys next time
good bye